bonjour à tous j'espère que vous êtes en
forme
on va aller un petit tour un petit tour
sur la mer comme on vous l'a dit donc je
suis là pour vous parler d'un projet qui
s'appelle 2e cycle in her et vous parler
un petit peu de la pollution maritime de
manière globale et de essayer de trouver
des solutions parce que aujourd'hui on
vous parle beaucoup de pollution en tout
genre de réchauffement climatique et en
général tout ça est très anxiogène et
finalement me manque un petit peu aussi
de solutions et de et d'objectifs de
trouver des solutions le futur et on va
essayer de mettre notre pierre à
l'édifice pour contribuer à ça alors moi
je veux bien un petit peu en arrière je
repars dans mon enfance donc l'âge de 8
ans je repars sur un tour du monde en
famille de 8 à 12 ans sur un voilier à
l'époque une navigation très épuré très
dépourvu de technologie et puis là-bas
un bonheur incroyable de naviguer
pendant toutes ces années sur une ou
parfaite une eau pure et nous
complètement dégagée de toute pollution
et voilà mes souvenirs d'enfance était
là et puis ensuite d'un retour retour à
la réalité retour à la civilisation des
années passées à faire des études puis
retour à la compétition retour au grand
large les routes du rhum la transat
jacques vabre et puis là de nombreux
abandons nombreuses collisions avec les
containers notamment puisqu'aujourd'hui
on rejette à peu près presque dix mille
containers par an à la mer et ses
collisions déjà mon interpeller quand
même me dit non seulement on risque
notre vie on t'apprend ces containers
mais en plus c'est une pollution
démentiel sachant qu'il ya seulement 10
% des containers qui reste à la
flottaison parce que les autres
finissent au fond de l'eau et puis bien
sûr tous les objets flottants non
identifiés et qui peuvent être de toutes
sortes de déchets en tout genre on sait
pas forcément ce qui ce que c'est parce
que tellement va vite sur l'eau
aujourd'hui
et puis là plus récemment un tour du
monde qui a duré deux ans de 2013 à 2015
ou là j'ai fait le choix de repartir sur
un tout petit bateau avait un cata de
sport un tout petit catamaran qui est
dépourvu d'électronique et là où je
navigue complètement un raz de l'eau je
suis vraiment sur un bateau qui fait 500
kg et l'âge du coup je vis au fil de la
nature au fil de voilà des eaux
effectivement dans l'océan indien entre
l'australie on va dire en longeant
l'indonésie le sri lanka la mer rouge
là je vois une mère qui est complètement
transformé et surtout je subis
pleinement cette cette pollution avec
des objets qui tape sur les coques avec
des filets qui freinent littéralement le
bateau avec une vision parfois d'horreur
de tous ces sacs plastiques à perte de
vue
ça m'est arrivé de m'arrêter qu'on sait
compter jusqu'à 100 déchets autour de
moi et puis évidemment quand on est sur
un petit bateau comme ça on voi regarde
l'horizon de manière permanente et c'est
ça tombe sous les yeux de manière
régulière et puis la mer rouge là c'est
carrément un océan une mère
d'hydrocarbures puisque maintenant les
bateaux des gaz dans de purement dans
cette mer et puis retour retour en
france
et là forcément très choqué de cette
expérience
ben je me réveille je me dis mais qu'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement pour agir et
pour aller ramasser ces déchets bastille
on ramasse nos déchets aujourd'hui
devant nos portes sont en marche même
les mégots dans les rues mais voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait concrètement quand
même pour agir voilà on se rend compte
qu'il ya quand même des belles actions
qui sont menées pour nettoyer les plages
pour mettre des systèmes qui vont bien
dans les marinas pour récupérer les
déchets dans un proche littoral
éventuellement mais pourra l'aider à
chercher des déchets en pleine mer rien
du tout donc là effectivement c'est là
qu'est nous est venue l'idée de créer 6
cleaner un concept original avec un
bateau qui serait mobile et qui
pourraient aller pourquoi pas chercher
ces déchets en mer donc là on a créé une
équipe surtout on a fait des études de
faisabilité et puis on s'est rendu
compte au fil de ses études en en
réalisant un monstre bateau qui serait
très très grand que finalement on
pourrait peut-être imaginer ramasser
jusqu'à 600 mètres cubes de plastique
alors il faut savoir que la pollution du
plastique dans les océans c'est à peu
près 8 millions de tonnes aujourd'hui le
plastique qui sont déversées chaque
année dans les océans donc c'est une
manière volontaire meilleur indirects
les pêcheurs par exemple c'est 15% la
pollution maritime ils font pas exprès
de perdre leurs filets ou de perdre
leurs boules de polystyrène mais
malheureusement elles existent et puis
c'est la bouteille d'eau qui est perdu à
200 kilomètres des côtes dans un rebord
d'un ruisseau qui finit dans le ruisseau
dans le dans le fleuve et filles qui
finit forcément toujours à la mer
aujourd'hui il faut savoir concrètement
que la population va passer de 6
milliards d'habitants à 9 milliards dhs
en 2050 et que la pollution de ces
plastiques va quasiment triplé
malgré tout les evs et tous les efforts
que vous allez faire vous allez on va
vous allez faire changer les habitudes
vous allez avoir une industrie qui est
beaucoup moins peu lente et malgré tout
ces bonbons capteurs tous ces bons
chiffres à la pollution va tripler
donc effectivement il faut intervenir en
eau sur le robinet mais pas seulement il
faut intervenir aussi à la mer parce que
ces 8 millions de tonnes qui vont
devenir 25 millions de tonnes
il faut bien en faire quelque chose ce
plastique c'est aussi une c'est pas
seulement un déchet c'est vraiment une
matière première et c'est là qu'il ya
une des choses à faire qui sont qui sont
concrètes parce que c'est ces
populations ces philippins qui gagne 80
dollars par mois ils se rendent même pas
compte que finalement ils jettent à la
mer des des billets de dollars 1 des
billets de dollars qui pourraient servir
à quelque chose parce que 1 kg de
plastique ségala 08 de pétrole donc
c'est ça peut être utilisée surtout le
plastique qu'on récupère de la mer ce
congé le plastique qui flottent écrit
qu'on récupère de main dans la main
forcément il est assez pur tant qu'il
n'est pas trop chargés de fleurs il est
encore assez pur il n'est pas chargé de
métaux d'autres d'autres d'autres
matières dont on peut vraiment leur
cycle est à peu près 1 81% donc je vous
propose de découvrir un petit film de 2
minutes qui présente un thibault le
projet et je vous en reparle après
du liquide vaisselle là sans les
intérêts voilà donc quoi j'ai navigué
pendant traite de son jumeau pendant mon
tour du monde
c'est absolument ignobles quand j'étais
en asie du sud est
clairement il fallait que je stocke le
bateau tous les quarts d'heure pour
enlever les morceaux de plastique pour
vraiment tapé du poing sur la table
aujourd'hui et intervenir aujourd'hui on
a à peu près deux morceaux de plastique
sur la planète océan pour cinq poissons
en 2050
c'est un morceau de plastique pour un
poisson la motta c'est tout simple c'est
le camion poubelle de la mer et il peut
ramasser tous types de déchets alors
évidemment principalement le plastique
parce que c'est ce qui flottent en
surface avec notamment les filets naïm
et j'ai d'abord le plus grand bateau
possible d'avoir le plus d'envergure
possible donc on mesure 72 mètres de
large et ce bateau est capable déjà de
ramasser 300 mètres cubes de déchets
rang seulement quelques semaines
l'intérêt justement du montage c'est
justement que c'est un navire donc il
peut se déplacer et on sait aujourd'hui
que sur les zones côtières c'est à dire
sur les zones où le plastique et
récemment mis à l'eau il est assez
concentré qu'on peut agir là sur le
plastique pendant qu'il est encore sous
forme de macrodéchets un bateau qui
pourrait à ramasser tout ce plastique ou
une partie de ce plastique et le
recycler ça serait ça serait aussi
formidable aujourd'hui le cycle in her
c'est pas de la communication c'est un
projet simple la construction d'un
bateau la capacité de ramasser 300
mètres cubes de plastique tous les mois
faux faux dieux résultat est il que ça
qui va compter pour nous
alors pour comprendre un petit peu le
cycle de vie d'un plastique le sac
plastique ou la bouteille d'eau qui se
retrouve à la mer en gros elle reste
dans sa forme originale à peu près
pendant un an
donc elle va dériver pendant un an à
plus ou moins en fonction évidemment des
zones où il ya du courant ou pas et
après qu'est ce qui va se passer là en
général la flore va pousser dessus et
pour la plupart des plastiques à peu
près 85 % et plastiques ils vont couler
et finir au fond de la mer parce que à
cause de la densité qui a changé
d'autres plastiques que vont se
détériorer et vont se décomposer en
espèce de micro particules qui sont des
billes de plastique d'environ 5 7 mm de
diamètre et c'est ce qu'on appelle lé
giro cyanide les océans de plastique les
les 7e continent dans milieu du
pacifique dont vous avez tous entendu
parler ce ne seront pas des chambres
plastique
ce sont vraiment des plastiques qui sont
presque invisibles mais qui sont sur des
colonnes d'eau de 0 à 100 mètres de
profondeur et quand on rend
effectivement au filtre l'eau par mètre
cube
on peut retrouver parfois plusieurs
centaines de microparticules de
plastique et ça évidemment c'est souvent
au bout de entre 2 et 7 8 ans de dérive
quand les plastiques finissent par
partir dans les courants océaniques bas
que la bassée plastique évidemment sont
plus du tout récupérables donc
évidemment l'intervention de cycle in
her c'est quoi c'est d'intervenir dans
la première année de dérives du
plastique temps qu'il est dans sa forme
originale et tant qu'il est récupérable
parce qu'après essayer de trouver des
systèmes pour les chats lutte et le fond
de la mer ou de ramasser ces micro
billes autant dire que c'est de ramasser
une épine dans une botte de foin
donc là c'est la mission déjà allé à les
ruines et déjà c'est le petit colibri
qui fait son action pour notre part mais
là autant dire ça serait quasiment
impossible donc il ya vraiment une vraie
urgence d'intervention parce que
évidemment c'est l'intel à la pollution
n'attend pas et donc le projet du mantas
et on est parti évidemment vous l'avez
vu sur un bateau très content très
compliqué qui fait 49 m de large la
largeur du canal de panama et qui va
faire 70 mètres de long
donc c'est un voilier parce
qu'évidemment on va pas les dépenses et
du
du kérosène du gasoil pour aller
chercher plastique ça serait une des
aînés une hérésie
donc on a imaginé un bateau très
puissant avec des marques qui sont si
grands que l'arc de triomphe 56 mètres
de haut et qui va fonctionner
principalement à la voile d'un plupart
du temps mais quand il y aura pas besoin
il pourra toujours fonctionné avec des
moteurs électriques parce que vous savez
votre maîtrise son trait propulsif ils
ont beaucoup de couples et on est là on
al'avantage d'avoir plein de des
énergies renouvelables qui fonctionne
très bien
cinq mille mètres carrés de panneaux
solaires parce que le bateau est très
large avec ses quatre coques et ça et sa
dimension
on a d hydrogène azul aulas qui peut qui
sont très très bon très bien pour
fabriquer l'énergie aussi et puis des
éoliennes à axe vertical qui vont
fabriquer l'énergie les éoliennes qu'on
est sur un bateau c'est encore mieux ça
n'existe pas aujourd'hui mais c'est
encore mieux parce que le bateau ils se
déplacent et en se déplaçant il fabrique
lui-même son vent donc forcément le vent
qui va souffrir l'éolienne va être
encore plus productif donc du coup de
bateaux mais il est en autonomie
complète au niveau énergétique et lui ne
pense pas de là pas une empreinte
carbone quand il va les ramasser ces
déchets plastiques par rapport à
d'autres systèmes qui peuvent exister
donc à partir de là comment ça va
fonctionner le bateau il va être à l'eau
en le premier en tout cas mental va être
à l'eau en 2020 après deux années
d'études et deux années de construction
là il ya un équipage à bord de 15
personnes qui va partir sur les zones
les plus contaminées
donc les zones les plus contaminées ce
sont principalement les zones côtières
on l'avait compris de 0 à 100 milles
souvent près des grandes villes comme
on compte toutes ces conduites qui
polluent énormément sorhouet la sortie
des grands fleuves comme le gange de
mékong et tous ces fleuves qui déversait
énormément et aujourd'hui en plus avec
les données scientifiques on a de météo
et de modèles de courant on arrive quand
même assez facilement à imaginer ou
est-ce que aller cette pollution et on
va aussi évidemment améliorer toutes ses
bases de données parce que l'objectif de
6 cleaner s'est pas seulement de les
collecter ces déchets plastiques
c'est aussi de récupérer des données
très forte sur la pollution des macro
déchets j'ai eu des expériences et des
expéditions intéressant ce retard assure
septième continent et autres mais
c'était plutôt sur des microparticules
de plastique et c'est souvent des
expéditions qui durent seulement
quelques semaines donc qui ramène des
données intéressant mais qui sont un
petit peu insuffisantes
là un bateau qui ratissent les océans
qui ramassent pendant 300 jours par an
600 mètres cubes de plastique par tous
les trois jours où tous les trois
semaines en fonction des zones
contaminées
forcément à chaque fois qu'on ramasse du
plastic bag est ce qu'on va faire on va
le on va le quantifier on va le
répertorier on va le cartographier et
donc forcément la base de données avec
de plus en plus intéressantes et avec
ses modèles de courant on pourra même
dire tiens le plastique qu'ils
rejetaient à cet endroit de l'eau
finalement trois semaines avant il a dû
être rejeté par le parlement compte par
exemple et donc forcément on va
améliorer aussi nos collectes au fil du
temps mais au fil des années et on
pourra communiquer encore mieux auprès
des populations qui pour lui peut-être
plus que puisque d'autres quoi donc
évidemment vous l'avez compris un bateau
ça serait pas suffisant il faudrait
développer ce bateau donc on va on va
déjà fabriqué le premier expliqué que ça
fonctionne que ça joue mais après l'idée
quand on aura un fonds financé ce bateau
avec les mécènes et c'est bien parti pou
on pourra aller voir les états ont pour
leur montrer les chiffres et leur dire
vous croyez pas qu'il faut faire quelque
chose et ce qu'on pense sincèrement que
ça doit pas forcément rentrer dans un
modèle économique forcément bien même si
on a un petit peu en tout cas sur une
partie ce que le plastique qui se revend
notamment 400 euros la tonne mais c'est
aussi parce que aujourd'hui on se pose
plus la question quand les camions
poubelles passe devant chez vous ça
coûte de l'argent à ces à la
collectivité
mais on le fait quoi pourquoi
aujourd'hui on n'irait pas dépenser un
peu d'argent pour les récupérer nos
plastique de la mer ça doit pas
forcément répondre qu'à
modèle économique et les états
effectivement doivent être impliqués des
connectivités mais ils vont pas le faire
dans un premier temps et nous c'est pas
notre volonté parce qu'on veut faire
avancer les choses rapidement
vous le savez avec ces collectivités
c'est toujours très long et et notre
bateau c'est déjà un projet de cinq ans
et on n'a pas envie que ce soit disant
ou 15 ans mais dans un deuxième temps
effectivement on ira voir toutes ces et
à tous ces collectivités
on ouvrira nos plans en open source pour
que tous ces étapes puisse s'approprier
le projet puisse s'approprier des plans
et puissent construire eux mêmes leur
propre bateau on a imaginé que 100
bateaux bien répartie sur les océans
on pense qu'à peu près 95 % la pollution
des macro déchets répartis sur 5 % des
océans vous voyez y a pas besoin d'aller
ratissé toute la surface des océans il
faut se concentrer sur les zones les
plus contaminées à peu près 60% la zone
la plus contaminée se trouve en asie du
sud est donc là évidemment il ya un gros
boulot et may à l'africa le goff de
granby à l'est de la méditerranée est la
côte est la côte ouest pendant des états
unis il ya beaucoup de zones qui sont
hautement hautement contaminée après ce
deuxième volet scientifique de ccleaner
il y en a un troisième qui est peut-être
même le plus important c'est l'éducation
et la sensibilisation parce que c'est
bien de collecter mais si ce n'est pas
pour faire changer les habitudes et les
comportements ça sert pas à grand chose
parce que l'objectif à terme ça c'est
que dans un siècle on ne pollue plus du
tout et donc si cleaner basse et une
plate forme c'est un bateau c'est
quelque chose de très visuel de très
médiatique
le bateau est très impressionnant il est
il est forcément il sera le plus grand
multicoque au monde et quand il va se
balader quand il va revenir dans les
ports parce qu'il faudra bien qui
revient dans ses ports pour décharger
les déchets plastiques pour faire la
maintenance du bateau est bien là le
troisième volet va rentrer en action et
une équipe l'équipe de cycle in her qui
sera composé de spécialistes de la
diplomatie de l'éducation de la
sensibilisation pour ont convoqué les
populations les décideurs les les
les acteurs politiques les gens qui sont
concernés dans ces pays là et pour on
pourra voir un message qui a été plutôt
assez fort parce que aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il ya vraiment une saturation
des
de l'écologie pour l'écologie c'est
beaucoup moi j'ai assisté au kop 22 à
tous et toutes ces conférences
il ya énormément de conférences et des
6000 conférence internationale sur
l'écologie vous rendez compte c'est
assez catastrophique donc c'est beaucoup
de blabla mais pas beaucoup d'action et
le simple fait d'être dans l'action de
se retrousser les manches
leur masse et ce plastique et de revenir
à quai et de déverser ses 6 ans michael
de plastique été renvoyé alors si on a
ramassé ces de plastique pendant
des semaines là devant vos côte est ce
que vous croyez pas aujourd'hui qu'on
peut faire quelque chose et on peut vous
aider pour ça parce qu'il existe des
solutions aux cycles âge il existe des
solutions pour traiter ses déchets et on
peut en faire quelque chose et donc là
effectivement le message est beaucoup
plus facile à passer le canton avec son
costard cravate et qu'on discute devant
ma personne dans un amphithéâtre donc
donc donc voilà voilà ce qu'on va
essayer de faire ça va prendre beaucoup
d'années beaucoup de temps mais on
compte en compte bien y arriver
après ben je vois toutes ces bouteilles
d'eau là sur vos sauts de table ça me
désespère un petit peu mais donc je
compte sur vous en prenez votre beauté
avec vous et puis essayer de la deûle à
trier parce que déjà le triage c'est une
première bonne étape mais vous savez
qu'en france on n'est pas forcément les
bons exemples déjà puisque on enfouit
50% du plastique sous terre encore il ya
que 50% du plastique recyclé donc on n'a
encore même en europe beaucoup d'efforts
à faire en la matière et pour vous
donner quelques quelques chiffres quand
même sur les actions qu'on veut mener
qui sont toutes simples aujourd'hui à
peu près si vous vous arrêtez de boire
de l'eau dans ses bouteilles d'eau la
queue qui sont devant vous si vous
arrêtez de prendre d'utiliser des sacs
plastiques
il ya des solutions avec kersauson par
exemple ils embarquaient 200 litres de
bois
vin en bouteille dans son bateau pour
son premier tour du monde et ils ont
quand même gagné donc donc ça n'a pas
nui à l'équipage et c'est sans le savoir
il pleuvait pas le kersauson oms a
changé un petit peu après mais mais mais
voilà boire de l'eau dans les bouteilles
en verre c'est déjà ça a déjà plus de
sens avoir des gourdes ça c'est vraiment
le bon geste d'avoir d'avoir sa gourde
avec soin et personne pour l'instant à
ce réflexe mais si vous ne buvez plus
ces de bouteilles d'eau si vous
ne consommez plus ces sacs plastiques
vous allez éviter 40 % de la pollution
des océans
donc évidemment les frais que c'est
toute la planète le fasse mais vous
voyez il n'y a pas besoin de faire grand
chose déjà pour que ça ça change
radicalement
voilà je vous remercie de m'avoir suivi
[Applaudissements]